Google Cloud updates Google for startups
accelerator security AI workbench and
security health analytics applications
are now open for the cloud cohort of the
inaugural North American Google for
startups accelerator apply before the
deadline on May 30th to join this
virtual 10-week accelerator now
generally available Google Cloud
security AI workbench an industry first
extensible platform that powers new
offerings to uniquely address three top
security challenges threat overload
toilsome tools and the talent Gap custom
modules for security health analytics is
now generally available and that means
you can now author custom detective
controls in security Command Center get
more on all those stories at the links
below we'll see you next week for more